[Music]
we're excited to see all our favorite
toys in Toy Story 4 but one beloved
character will not be returning keep
watching to find out the real reason
that Kim is not in the latest Toy Story
movie we first met Ken in Toy Story 3 he
was living at Sunnyside daycare he was
one of the first toys that all of Andy's
toys meets when they got there he was
one of the leaders of the daycare toys
and when he met Barbie it was love at
first sight Ken became immediately
smitten with Barbie he said it was like
he even asked Barbie to move into his
dream house with him right after they
met but then Ken turned into a bit of a
villain she was lot so right hand man
and he helped in prison woody and the
gang when they tried to leave he seemed
pretty cruel but love conquers all in
Disney movies Barbie tricks him into
letting her outs and his feelings were
so strong that he gave in he showed her
his closets and modeled a bunch of
outfits for her and one of the funniest
scenes ever but Barbie is one tough girl
she attacked him and interrogated him on
how to save Buzz Lightyear at the end of
the movie Ken betrayed lot so he did the
right thing and ends up nearly being
destroyed at the dump he did all of that
for Barbies so we were pretty sure that
they would be together forever but
director Josh Cooley recently revealed
some bad news
ken is not in Toy Story 4 he has said
that Ken is back at Sunnyside but we
know that barbie is still with woody and
the rest of Bonnie's toys so what
exactly happened between the happy
couple and why did these two lovebirds
choose to call it quits we've got some
pretty great theories for what went down
between the 3rd and 4th movies
[Music]
there are a lot of toys at Sunnyside and
without a leader there would be total
chaos
Lotso kept things under control but he
was totally evil with lots o gone all
the toys at Sunnyside have no one to
look to for guidance they need someone
to keep order and handle conflicts ken
was part of matzos inner circle he knows
his way around the daycare he knows
every toy that lives there too and he
turned out to be a pretty great guy he
really cares about all the toys at
Sunnyside he is the natural choice for
the new leader and all the Sunnyside
toys would absolutely listen to him they
know that he cares for them being in
charge of a whole daycare full of toys
is no easy job but Ken is definitely the
most qualified we see him take over at
the end of the third movie then there's
big baby you might remember the super
creepy baby doll from Toy Story 3 this
doll was basically lots of muscle he
enforced a lot of lots of evil policies
because he was told to but he is a baby
he doesn't even know how to speak unless
you count baby talk he needs someone to
care for him and tells him what to do
big baby isn't evil because babies
aren't evil at the end of the third film
we see him wearing a gold diaper that
matches Ken and Barbies outfits it
basically looks like Ken and Barbie had
plans to adopt him
ken cared a lot for big baby and if
Barbie and Ken are together he can have
a mom and dad
Kim would never leave big baby behind
they've been together for years he
wouldn't trust anyone else to take care
of the doll all of this makes total
sense we absolutely understand why Ken's
stay behind at Sunnyside the why aren't
Ian Barbie together barbie is for sure
in Toy Story for Pixar released a clip
of Bo Peep rescuing a lost toy woody
buzz Jessie and slink are there too bo
tells her sheep to open the window then
she yells for the Barbies to help that's
when we see our beloved Barbie from
previous movies and she is with two
other Barbie dolls they helped launch
Jessie in the air to unlock the window
so it's safe to assume that Barbie moved
out of Ken's dream house but Barbie and
Ken seem so happy at the end of Toy
Story 3 we thought for sure she would
stay with Ken if push came to shove well
it turns out that this Barbie and Ken
weren't really made
each other ken was a pretty good guy but
he was also really shallow and there was
one thing he loved more than Barbie
clothes Bobby likes fashion just as much
as the next doll but Ken's obsession
with his clothes was next-level think
about the scene where Barbie interrogate
him she ties him up and how does she get
him to talk she doesn't hurt him she
hurts his clothes he cares so much about
his clothes that it was literal torture
when Barbie destroyed them ken let his
love of clothes get between him and
Barbie and let's be honest there is no
way she would give her any space in the
closet Barbie may like fancy outfits but
after living with Andy's toys for so
long she knows what's really important
in life and Barbie deserves to be a
priority she would never settle for
someone treating clothes better than her
Ken's fashion hobby was just too much
for Barbie Bobby also had a really hard
time leaving her family Andy's toys have
been together for a long time they all
look out for each other and it looks
like she has made some pretty great
friends with Bonnie's other Barbie dolls
it's really for the best that she and
Ken broke up Ken is keeping an eye on
all the toys at Sunnyside and doing an
awesome job at it which toys are you
most excited about to see again in Toy
Story 4 let us know in the comments
thanks for watching the things give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe we'll see you next time
[Music]